the Joe Rogan experience you can put up
content of your own you can do anything
on your own I mean so many people like
Tim Dylan perfect example oh by the way
was that him in drag
it's him as Megan McCain oh I got
blocked by her you did on Twitter yeah
Tim Dylan of course he did I did you get
Blackfyre I just said something on
Twitter it was just kind of like I don't
remember but I I told her to [ __ ]
calm down and now she's like she's my
father my father my father my father and
now she's like I love gay people and I'm
like okay [ __ ] um but yeah she she but
if that's a good stamp of approval to
getting past my midsi getting blocked by
Meghan McCain well she blocked him Dylan
and he was who's very excited about it's
kind of an epic thing I got blocked by a
Chloe grace Moretz and who's that she's
an actress why'd she block you cuz I
yelled at her in a movie theater
whoa she was on her phone really yeah
and I was watching the purge so I was
like in the moment she was talking on
the phone and a [ __ ] movie notice
what she was on it she was like checking
Instagram full brightness just no yeah
and she was sitting in the front and I
oh I was livid I've talked about this
several times and I'm still if I
couldn't how did she know that it was
you she didn't know it was me because it
was dark and I went over and screamed at
her and told her could offer [ __ ]
phone then I turned around the audience
started clapping because everyone was
pissed so I was a movie hero and then as
I went out someone was like that's the
girl you were yelling at and paparazzi
were all around her and I was like oh
I'm taking this step I'm gonna tweet and
I started tweeting at her saying hey
[ __ ] get off you're fronting movie
theater especially if you're an actress
and we're paying money to see you doing
movies you know and then she blocked me
so then I wasn't done yet
I'd sweeted her boyfriend at the Times
mom who happens to be Victoria Beckham
posh spice and was like hey your son's
dating an [ __ ] you know who didn't
block me Victoria Beckham she probably
didn't like her either yeah but she
didn't [ __ ] her son she's probably
angry
that dirty [ __ ] get her bad breath over
my son's dick God wait I just got a
notification she just blocked you on
Twitter
you made it good I don't check oh my god
blocked me all day on Twitter I won't
never notice who's the most famous
person who's ever blocked to you I don't
have no idea you don't know you're there
I stopped reading Twitter mentions and
all that stuff a long time ago I need to
get better at that
I don't read [ __ ] I'm gonna do it though
I'm gonna read these comments why
because it kind of gets me hard you
think I think the whole premise of
comments is fascinating to me how
someone takes time out of their day to
just like you know it just blows my mind
you know and it's funny because
sometimes they're very supportive like
once once I left the show you know
people are coming and tagging me and
stuff and being like we want Justin back
where's Justin the show's not the same
and I'm just kind of like well it ran
its course you know I did my thing and
I'm moving on right but it just it's
just so funny how some people are just
like you know it did what's it called
lights out with David Spade the other
day and there was like get this [ __ ]
off
I know it's just but it makes me laugh
because I'm like well who's on the show
me not you
so mmm who's the [ __ ] now
[Applause]